This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. It seems like the simplest choice in the world. Given the option between pain and pleasure, we ought to choose pleasure. Is it better to be hungry or full, better to be tired or alert, better to watch another episode of our favorite TV show or do the dishes? It is in just our own minds that tell us to choose the path of enjoyment and indulgence. Our friends remind us that life is short, say no to dessert or another round of drinks and someone might call you a spoil sport. At Stanford University, psychiatrist Ana Lemke
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这似乎是世界上最简单的选择。在痛苦和快乐之间，我们理应选择快乐。是饿着肚子好还是吃饱了好？是疲惫好还是清醒好？是再看一集最喜欢的电视剧好，还是去洗碗好？正是我们自己的大脑在告诉我们要选择享受和放纵的道路。朋友们提醒我们人生苦短，如果拒绝甜点或再来一杯酒，可能会被说成是扫兴的人。在斯坦福大学，精神病学家安娜·伦姆克
has heard the same messages. But as a scientist, she's also studied the way our brain's balance, pain and pleasure. The two sit on opposite ends of a neural seesaw, and the brain constantly attempts to bring them into equilibrium, or what is known as homeostasis. When we press down hard and often on the pleasure side of the seesaw, triggering bursts of the neurotransmitter dopamine, Ana says the brain automatically compensates by pressing down on the other side, producing a dopamine deficit. Over time, as people press down too much or too often on the pleasure side of the equation,
也听过同样的说法。但作为一名科学家，她也研究了我们大脑平衡痛苦和快乐的方式。两者位于神经跷跷板的两端，大脑不断试图使它们达到平衡，也就是所谓的稳态。当我们用力且频繁地压向跷跷板的快乐一侧，触发神经递质多巴胺的爆发时，安娜说大脑会自动通过压向另一侧来进行补偿，从而产生多巴胺赤字。随着时间的推移，当人们在等式的快乐一侧压得太用力或太频繁时，
the brain compensates so forcefully that we start to walk around with a chronic dopamine deficit. This can manifest as anxiety, irritability, and depression. There is complex neurochemistry behind the process of homeostasis, but Ana has come up with a simple way to visualize this. When you press down on one side of the seesaw, imagine a bunch of gremlins inside your head, jumping on the other side of the seesaw. We explore how this mechanism works and why it exists in our previous episode. If you missed it, I strongly suggest you listen to it first. Today, we continue with the second part of our story
大脑会进行强有力的补偿，以至于我们开始带着长期的多巴胺赤字生活。这可能表现为焦虑、易怒和抑郁。稳态的过程背后有着复杂的神经化学机制，但安娜想出了一种简单的方法来形象化这一点。当你压下跷跷板的一侧时，想象一下你脑子里有一群小妖精，正跳到跷跷板的另一侧。我们在上一集中探讨了这种机制是如何运作的以及它为什么存在。如果你错过了，我强烈建议你先去听那一集。今天，我们继续讲述故事的第二部分，
about the paradoxical effects of pleasure. And we ask what it means to live a life of balance and harmony. How to work with the brain, rather against it, this week on Hidden Brain. Anna Lemke is a psychiatrist at Stanford University. She has worked with many patients who have addictions, not just to drugs like cocaine and heroin, but to everyday activities taken to excess. She has treated patients with a range of out-of-control indulgences, from eating and drinking, to online shopping, and sports betting. Around the time she turned 40, Anna found herself
关于快乐的矛盾效应。我们探讨了过一种平衡与和谐的生活意味着什么。本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨如何与大脑合作，而不是对抗它。安娜·伦姆克是斯坦福大学的精神病学家。她曾治疗过许多患有成瘾症的患者，不仅是对可卡因和海洛因等毒品的成瘾，还有对过度沉迷于日常活动的成瘾。她治疗过各种失控放纵的患者，从饮食和饮酒，到网络购物和体育博彩。在40岁左右的时候，安娜发现自己
in the grip of an addiction. She was consumed with romance novels and erotic. At one point, she found herself swept up in the novel, 50 Shades of Grey. The story, later made into a movie, revolves around a sadomasochistic relationship between a college student and a business tycoon. There's some people who say that I don't have a heart at all. Why would they say that? Because they know me well. Do you have any interest outside of work?
陷入了成瘾的泥潭。她沉迷于浪漫小说和情色作品。有一次，她发现自己沉浸在小说《五十度灰》中。这个后来被改编成电影的故事，围绕着一名女大学生和一位商业大亨之间的虐恋关系展开。有些人说我根本没有心。他们为什么会这么说？因为他们很了解我。除了工作，你还有什么兴趣吗？
Enjoy various physical pursuits. I asked Anna what drew her to the book. I'm honestly not even sure I know, because it didn't really matter when I was reading it. That is to say like the plot and the characters matter not at all. I was reading it for the sex scenes. You know, embarrassing to admit that, but it's true. But I remember rationalizing it to myself as a modern day pride and prejudice. But you know, not really. Yeah, you don't think Jane Austin would have written 50 shades of gray.
享受各种体育活动。我问安娜是什么吸引她读那本书。老实说，我甚至不确定自己是否知道，因为我在读的时候，内容其实并不重要。也就是说，情节和人物根本不重要。我读它只是为了看性爱场景。你知道，承认这一点很尴尬，但这是事实。但我记得我曾为自己辩解，说这是现代版的《傲慢与偏见》。但你知道，其实并不是。是的，你不认为简·奥斯汀会写出《五十度灰》。
Don't think so. No, don't think so. So at a certain point, Anna, you started to see that your enjoyment of romance novels and fantasy had tipped over from entertainment to something more potent. When did you have this realization as you were reading 50 Shades of Grey? I remember it vividly. It was about three in the morning on a weeknight.
不这么认为。不，不这么认为。那么在某个时刻，安娜，你开始意识到你对浪漫小说和幻想的享受已经从娱乐变成了更强烈的某种东西。当你读《五十度灰》时，你是什么时候意识到这一点的？我记得很清楚。那是一个工作日的凌晨三点左右。
Well, past the hour, I should have been sleeping so that I could be prepared for the next day to come. And I got to a scene where, you know, the characters were using say to massacistic sex toys. And I just thought to myself, well, how did I get here? What am I doing? That's not anything that I'm into or even interested in. It was this sort of like where am I? And how did this happen? And I decided, that's it. This is something that's gone seriously right here. I need to look at this problem.
嗯，过了我本该睡觉的时间，这样我才能为第二天做好准备。我读到了一个场景，你知道，角色们在使用虐恋性玩具。我当时就想，我怎么会在这里？我在做什么？这根本不是我喜欢甚至感兴趣的东西。这就像是一种“我在哪儿？这是怎么发生的？”的感觉。我决定，够了。这绝对是出大问题了。我需要正视这个问题。
Ana eventually came to realize that her own engagement with romance novels and erotica had something in common with the addictions she was treating in her patients. When she was reading, she would become so engrossed that it felt like she was treating in her patients. When she was reading, she would become so engrossed that it felt like she was in a trance. You can see this among people who have addictions to sports betting or pornography. You can see it among heavy users of YouTube or social media platforms like TikTok. And of course,
安娜最终意识到，她自己对浪漫小说和情色作品的沉迷，与她正在治疗的患者的成瘾行为有共同之处。当她阅读时，她会变得如此专注，以至于感觉自己进入了恍惚状态。你可以在那些沉迷于体育博彩或色情制品的人身上看到这一点。你也可以在YouTube或TikTok等社交媒体平台的重度用户身上看到这一点。当然，
you can see it in the way people disappear into their phones. Anna said she would lose track of time, lose track of herself. And you know, we want to be in a trance. And I think that's something we have to admit to ourselves. We want to escape ourselves. And I think part of that is a function of this incredibly narcissistic society that we live in where we're so preoccupied with ourselves and our problems and our achievements.
你也可以在人们沉迷于手机的方式中看到这一点。安娜说她会忘记时间，迷失自我。你知道，我们想要进入恍惚状态。我认为这是我们必须向自己承认的一点。我们想要逃避自我。我认为这在一定程度上是我们所处的这个极其自恋的社会的一种功能，我们太过于关注自己、自己的问题和自己的成就。
Like we're desperate to get away from ourselves. Plus, you know, you have all these amazing drugs that make that possible. So a turning point in your life came in 2011 during an encounter you had with a young resident who was training to be a psychiatrist. Tell me what happened and how it came about. Yeah, so this was a, you know, lovely young student of mine, Dr. in his residency for psychiatry. And I was teaching a small group of residents how to do something called motivational
就像我们迫切地想要逃离自己一样。而且，你知道，你还有所有这些能让这种逃避成为可能的神奇药物。所以，你生命中的一个转折点出现在2011年，当时你遇到了一位正在接受精神科培训的年轻住院医生。告诉我发生了什么，以及它是如何发生的。是的，这是一个非常可爱的年轻学生，当时正在进行精神科住院医师培训。我正在教一小群住院医生如何进行所谓的动机
interviewing, which is a way of harnessing the patient's own motivation to change their behavior. So we got into these pairs so that one could roleplay the psychiatrist and the other could roleplay the patient. And the patient could talk about a behavior that they want to change and the psychiatrist could do this motivational interviewing to try to explore how to help them do that. And, you know, we had an odd number. So that means that I had to pair with the student in order to do the role play. So he said, well, I'll be the psychiatrist. I said, okay, I'll be the patient. And he said, you know, is there a behavior you'd like to change? And I just sort of said without even thinking about it, yeah, you know some late night reading that I'd like to change. And unusual motivational
访谈，这是一种利用患者自身动力来改变其行为的方法。我们分成了小组，这样一个人可以扮演精神科医生，另一个人可以扮演患者。患者可以谈论他们想要改变的行为，而精神科医生可以进行这种动机访谈，试图探索如何帮助他们做到这一点。而且，你知道，我们的人数是单数。这意味着我必须和学生配对来进行角色扮演。所以他说，好吧，我来当精神科医生。我说，好的，我来当患者。他说，你知道，有什么行为是你想要改变的吗？我甚至没多想就说，是的，你知道有一些深夜阅读的习惯我想改变。在非典型的动机
interviews, Tyler said, well, why is it that you want to change that behavior? You're trying to explore what the patient, what their reasons are. And I said, well, I just think it's gotten into a bad habit. It's interfering with my sleep, it's interfering with my ability to be present, you know, just sort of vague generalities. I did not tell him what specific genre of book I was struggling with. So then he asked me, what would you be giving up if you stopped that behavior? And I said, I would be giving up the intense pleasure and feeling of
访谈中，泰勒问，好吧，你为什么想要改变那种行为？你是在试图探索患者的理由是什么。我说，嗯，我只是觉得这已经变成了一个坏习惯。它干扰了我的睡眠，干扰了我保持专注的能力，你知道，只是一些模糊的概括。我没有告诉他我正在纠结的是哪种类型的书。然后他问我，如果你停止那种行为，你会放弃什么？我说，我会放弃阅读带来的强烈快感和
escape that I get from reading. But then when I said that, I realized, yeah, but those things are not as important to me as being present for my husband and for my children, for being invested in and good at the work that I do. So I find it so striking and also so revealing on that it took an actual conversation with someone, asked you a simple question and you had to answer aloud for you to see something Viking and also so revealing on that it took an actual conversation with someone asked you a simple question and you had to answer aloud for you to see something about yourself. I mean, you're the trained psychiatrist, you're supposed to have insight and I think it
逃避感。但当我这么说的时候，我意识到，是的，但这些对我来说并不像陪伴我的丈夫和孩子，以及投入并做好我的工作那样重要。我觉得这太令人震惊，也太有启发性了，因为这需要与某人进行一次真正的对话，对方问你一个简单的问题，而你必须大声回答，才能让你看到关于自己的一些事情。我的意思是，你是受过训练的精神科医生，你应该有洞察力，我认为这
just shows how difficult it is for all of us to see ourselves clearly. Yeah, isn't that amazing? And it is striking and a bit of a mystery, frankly, as to why putting into words what we're doing, especially telling another live human, has this remarkable ability to penetrate our lack of awareness and make us aware in a way that also then greatly enables our ability to change that behavior. So did the conversation end there or did the two of you come up with a plan for what you could do to change your behavior? The conversation as I'm recalling it went on a little bit longer, but not much longer, frankly.
恰恰说明了我们所有人想要清晰地看清自己是多么困难。是的，这不是很神奇吗？坦率地说，这确实令人震惊，也有点神秘，为什么把我们正在做的事情诉诸语言，特别是告诉另一个活生生的人，具有这种非凡的能力，能够穿透我们缺乏的意识，让我们意识到这一点，从而极大地增强我们改变该行为的能力。那么对话就在那里结束了吗？还是你们两个制定了一个计划，关于你可以做些什么来改变你的行为？据我回忆，对话又持续了一会儿，但坦率地说，没多久。
So then he asked a very simple question. He said, well, what's one thing you could do to take a step toward changing that behavior? And I thought, well, I could get rid of my Kindle, because my Kindle gives me such incredible easy access to these downloadable reads, including free reads from Amazon, that if I got rid of it, it would create a barrier between me and the romance novel so that I'd have to do more work to get it. So that's what I decided to do.
然后他问了一个非常简单的问题。他说，好吧，你可以做的一件事是什么，向改变那种行为迈出一步？我想，嗯，我可以扔掉我的Kindle，因为我的Kindle让我能极其容易地获取这些可下载的读物，包括亚马逊上的免费读物，如果我把它扔掉，它就会在我与浪漫小说之间建立一道屏障，这样我就必须付出更多努力才能得到它。所以我决定这样做。
So how did that go? Did you just quit cold turkey? Once I had had that conversation with him and I thought about it the next day, I had a moment where I realized, oh wow, I think I've developed a minor addiction to romance novels and eroticum. And so then I, I essentially made a decision to do what I recommend my patients do, which is abstain for four weeks, got rid of the Kindle, and just, you know, made a strong commitment to not reading romance novels and eroticum.
那么进展如何？你是直接彻底戒断了吗？一旦我和他进行了那次谈话，第二天我思考了一下，我有一个瞬间意识到，哦哇，我想我已经对浪漫小说和情色作品产生了轻微的成瘾。所以，我基本上做出了一个决定，去做我建议我的患者做的事情，那就是禁欲四周，扔掉了Kindle，并且，你知道，坚定地承诺不读浪漫小说和情色作品。
But what shocked me was that very night, which was the first 24-hour period of my not engaging in romance novel reading as a way to put myself to sleep. I was gripped by anxiety and restlessness and agitation. And I was surprised, right? Because I, first of all, didn't think there would be a huge physiologic or even psychological response, but I experienced withdrawal. The same kind of withdrawal that my patients described. Wow. I had a very difficult time putting myself to sleep. And so it was extremely difficult. I lay awake for several hours and finally was able to you know put myself to sleep. And that went on for about 10 to 14 days. So in fact, it was
但让我震惊的是，就在那天晚上，也就是我没有通过阅读浪漫小说来让自己入睡的第一个24小时周期，我被焦虑、不安和烦躁所困扰。我很惊讶，对吧？因为首先，我没想到会有巨大的生理甚至心理反应，但我经历了戒断反应。和我患者描述的同样的戒断反应。哇。我很难让自己入睡。所以这极其困难。我躺着清醒了好几个小时，最后才终于能够，你知道，让自己入睡。这种情况持续了大约10到14天。所以事实上，是
the process of trying to give it up that really brought home to me how addicted I had become. What happened at the end of the month? I felt much better, and I thought to myself, I'm good. Now I'm going to go back to reading romance novels now and then in a very rational and tempered way, and we're all gonna be fine here. And so I went and, you know, I got some book and I completely bingeed.
试图放弃的过程真正让我体会到我变得有多么上瘾。月底发生了什么？我感觉好多了，我对自己说，我好了。现在我要偶尔以一种非常理性且节制的方式回去读浪漫小说，我们都会没事的。于是我去，你知道，找了一些书，然后我完全沉迷其中。
I spent the whole weekend reading all day every day and late into the night on Sunday, went to work, Blirriide and Monday, and I realized, well, that was a complete mess. And it's clear that whatever those circuits are that have been kindled in my brain, they're still kindled and that a month is not sufficient and I need to recommit to a longer period of abstinence and that's what I did. I recommitted to a year of abstinence from romance novels,
我整个周末都在阅读，每天整天都在读，周日一直读到深夜，周一去上班时昏昏沉沉，我意识到，好吧，那简直是一团糟。很明显，无论大脑中被点燃的是什么回路，它们仍然被点燃着，一个月是不够的，我需要重新承诺更长时间的禁欲，这就是我所做的。我重新承诺禁欲一年，不读浪漫小说，
erotica of any sort. One of the things that's hardest about problems involving the mind is that we need our minds to battle the problems we have with our minds. Imagine trying to fix a broken toaster and the only tool you have is a very same broken toaster. When we come back, how to reset our relationship to pain and pleasure in a way that produces enduring satisfaction? You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In our previous episode, which I highly recommend you listen to if you haven't heard it yet, Stanford University psychiatrist Anna Lemke explained how our minds come with an internal
任何形式的情色作品。关于大脑的问题，最困难的事情之一就是我们需要大脑来对抗我们大脑中存在的问题。想象一下试图修理一个坏掉的烤面包机，而你唯一的工具就是同一个坏掉的烤面包机。当我们回来时，如何以一种产生持久满足感的方式重置我们与痛苦和快乐的关系？你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在我们上一集中，如果你还没听过，我强烈建议你去听一下，斯坦福大学精神病学家安娜·伦姆克解释了我们的大脑是如何自带一个内部
seesaw. It's designed to keep things in balance to achieve what is called homeostasis. When you bite into a delicious dessert or bet on a sports game and wait excitedly for the result, you're pressing on the pleasure side of the CISO. You trigger a burst of dopamine. To return to balance, the brain compensates by pressing down on the other side of the CISO. Over time, if we press too hard or too often on the pleasure side, the brain starts to compensate more and more forcefully leaving us with a dopamine deficit. This can leave us feeling down and miserable
跷跷板的。它的设计目的是保持平衡，以实现所谓的稳态。当你咬下一口美味的甜点，或者在体育比赛中下注并兴奋地等待结果时，你就是在压向跷跷板的快乐一侧。你触发了多巴胺的爆发。为了回到平衡，大脑通过压向跷跷板的另一侧来进行补偿。随着时间的推移，如果我们压向快乐一侧太用力或太频繁，大脑开始越来越强有力地进行补偿，让我们陷入多巴胺赤字。这会让我们感到沮丧和痛苦，
and prompt us to go find our next jolt of pleasure. You can see how this quickly can become a vicious cycle. Ana, it's clear that simply seeking out more pleasure and more intense pleasure or more constant pleasure is not the answer. And you often recommend something that you call a dopamine fast to your patients. How does it work? Well, the dopamine fast is a little bit of a misnomer in the sense that we're not actually
并促使我们去寻找下一次快乐的冲击。你可以看出这很快就会变成一个恶性循环。安娜，很明显，仅仅寻求更多的快乐、更强烈的快乐或更持续的快乐并不是答案。你经常向你的患者推荐一种你称之为“多巴胺禁食”的方法。它是如何运作的？嗯，“多巴胺禁食”这个说法有点用词不当，因为我们实际上并不是
ingesting dopamine. In fact, what we're doing is using substances and behaviors that trigger the release or increase in firing in dopamine that we make in our brain. What the dopamine fast refers to is to abstain from the substance or behavior. For long enough, for our brain to get the memo, oh, wait a minute, I'm not getting this external source anymore. It's time for me to start to make more of my own endogenous Oh, wait a minute. I'm not getting this external source anymore.
在摄入多巴胺。事实上，我们所做的是使用那些触发我们大脑中多巴胺释放或增加放电的物质和行为。“多巴胺禁食”指的是戒除该物质或行为。时间足够长，让大脑收到信号：哦，等等，我不再从外部获取这个来源了。是时候让我开始制造更多我自己的内源性……哦，等等，我不再从外部获取这个来源了。
It's time for me to start to make more of my own endogenous or innate dopamine to upregulate our dopamine receptors and increase dopamine transmission. Because in response to substances and behaviors that release a lot of dopamine in our brain, this fire hose of dopamine, what our brains essentially do is down-regulate dopamine transmission, not just a baseline, but below baseline, which is this state that's really akin to a clinical depression. There is an important caveat to this recommendation. The more severe the addiction, the more a dopamine fast will produce painful symptoms known as withdrawal. In some cases, withdrawal can be
是时候让我开始制造更多我自己的内源性或先天多巴胺，以上调我们的多巴胺受体并增加多巴胺传递。因为为了响应那些在我们大脑中释放大量多巴胺的物质和行为，这种多巴胺的“消防水带”，我们的大脑本质上所做的是下调多巴胺传递，不仅是降到基线，而是降到基线以下，这是一种非常类似于临床抑郁的状态。这个建议有一个重要的警告。成瘾越严重，多巴胺禁食产生的痛苦症状（即戒断反应）就越明显。在某些情况下，戒断反应可能
so severe that it can pose medical risks of its own. Anybody with a severe addiction is going to need medical supervision and support, and especially if they're physiologically dependent to a chemical like alcohol, or benzodiazepines, or opioids, such that they would be at risk for life-threatening withdrawal. Because essentially what happens in withdrawal is that we experience the opposite of whatever that drug does for us. And with sedatives like alcohol, opioids, and benzos, we can experience a physiologic storm,
非常严重，以至于会带来自身的医疗风险。任何有严重成瘾的人都需要医疗监督和支持，特别是如果他们在生理上依赖于酒精、苯二氮卓类药物或阿片类药物等化学物质，以至于他们有生命危险的戒断风险。因为本质上，戒断反应中发生的是，我们经历了该药物为我们所做的一切的对立面。对于酒精、阿片类药物和苯二氮卓类药物等镇静剂，我们可能会经历一场生理风暴，
including life-threatening seizures. So individuals who are struggling with that kind of severe chemical dependency should not just quit cold turkey. They need medically monitored detoxification or tapering in order to get off of their drug of choice. But the principle is still the same, you know, that they need to get off of that chemical in order to allow their brain to heal. So you once treated a patient whom you called the lyla, a young woman who was a heavy user of cannabis.
包括危及生命的癫痫发作。因此，那些正在与这种严重化学依赖作斗争的人不应该直接彻底戒断。他们需要医学监测下的排毒或减量，以便戒掉他们选择的药物。但原则仍然是一样的，你知道，他们需要戒掉那种化学物质，以便让大脑自我修复。所以你曾经治疗过一位你称之为“莱拉”的患者，她是一位大麻重度使用者。
So you broached the idea of a dopamine fast to her and what was her reaction? Well, first of all, she came to me seeking help for anxiety and depression, not seeking help for cannabis. In fact, she identified cannabis as the only thing that helped with her anxiety. And she wanted me to prescribe a pill or offer some kind of psychotherapy that would help with her anxiety and depression. But what I said to her, which is what I say to many people who now come to me wanting help with anxiety and depression, other psychiatric symptoms, whom I discover are using high dopamine rewards
所以你向她提出了“多巴胺禁食”的想法，她的反应是什么？嗯，首先，她来找我是为了寻求焦虑和抑郁的帮助，而不是为了大麻。事实上，她认为大麻是唯一能帮助她缓解焦虑的东西。她希望我开药或提供某种心理治疗来帮助她缓解焦虑和抑郁。但我对她说的话——这也是我对现在许多来找我寻求焦虑和抑郁帮助，而我发现他们正在过度使用高多巴胺奖励的患者所说的话——是，与其给他们开药或推荐任何心理治疗，我邀请他们做的是进行一个实验，即进行四周的多巴胺禁食，以重置奖励通路，因为我告诉他们，有一种可能性是，仅仅通过这样做，他们的焦虑和抑郁可能会在不进行任何其他干预的情况下得到显著改善。所以这就是我建议莱拉做的。
excessively, is that instead of prescribing them a pill or recommending any kind of psychotherapy, what I invite them to do is to engage in an experiment, which is the dopamine fast for four weeks in order to reset reward pathways, because there's a possibility I tell them that just by doing that alone, their anxiety and depression may get substantially better without having to do any other intervention. So that's what I suggested to do, ILA.
所以你认为四周的禁欲对于开始更清晰地看待自己的生活，准确感知当涉及到我们的情绪以及那些让我们情绪起伏的事物时的因果关系也是必要的。你是什么意思？这对莱拉来说效果如何？当我们追逐多巴胺时，
So you see that four weeks of extension are also necessary to begin to see one's life more clearly, to accurately perceive cause and effect when it comes to our moods and the things that are bringing us up and down. What do you mean by that? And how did that work out with Delilah? When we're chasing dopamine,
很难看到我们选择的药物（无论是物质还是行为）对我们生活的真正影响。我们看到的只是它带给我们的即时缓解。我们无法看到，随着时间的推移，正在发生的事情是我们正在以一种可能加剧我们试图解决的问题的方式改变我们的大脑。所以我建议莱拉尝试戒掉大麻
it's very difficult to see the true impact of our drug of choice, whether a substance or behavior on our lives. All we see is the immediate relief that we get from it. We're not able to see that over time, what's happening is that we're changing our brains in a way that's probably exacerbating the problem we're trying to solve. So I suggested to Delilah that she try giving up cannabis for a
一个月，以重置她的奖励通路。她对我说的是，你知道，我为什么要那样做？你知道，大麻是唯一能帮助我缓解焦虑的东西。我对她说，我听到了，你在那一刻确实从大麻中得到了缓解，但我建议你的是，你真正做的是在缓解上一次用药后的戒断反应，而不是在治疗你潜在的焦虑症。事实上，大麻随着时间的推移正在改变你的快乐或愉悦基准点，以至于现在你需要越来越多的大麻才能感受到任何快乐。
month in order to reset her reward pathways. And what she said to me is, you know, why would I do that? You know, cannabis is the only thing that helps with my anxiety. And I said to her, I hear you that in the moment you get relief from the cannabis, but what I suggest to you is that what you're really doing is medicating withdrawal from the last dose rather than treating your underlying anxiety disorder. And that in fact, what the cannabis is doing over time is changing your hedonic or joy set point such that now you need more and more cannabis to feel any pleasure at all.
事实上，我看到的是，使用大麻的人，大麻实际上可能开始产生相反的效果，随着时间的推移让他们变得更加焦虑，甚至偏执。尽管如此，她还是没有兴趣停止。她说，你知道，也许有一天，但不是现在。然后我做了我经常对患者做的事情，我试图让他们看看他们生命中更长的时间线。所以我对她说，好吧，我听到了你现在不想停止。你认为你什么时候想改变你使用大麻的方式？
And in fact, what I see is that people who use cannabis that the pot can actually start to do the opposite and make them more anxious and even paranoid over time. And still, she was not interested in stopping. She said, you know, maybe someday, but not now. And then I do something that I often do with patients and I try to get them to look at the larger timeline of their lives. So I said to her, well, I hear you that you're not interested in stopping now. When do you think you do want to change the way you're using cannabis?
你认为你10年后还想像现在这样抽吗？她立即回答，不，我10年后绝对不会像现在这样抽。你知道，暗示她目前的某种使用方式是她可以承认不健康的。所以我对她说，好吧，你不想在10年后这样抽。5年后怎么样？她说，不，我不想在5年后这样抽。我说，好吧，1年后怎么样？然后她停下来思考了一下。她说，好吧，我明白你的意思了，医生。
Do you think you want to be smoking the way you are now in 10 years? She immediately responded, nope, I definitely won't be smoking the way you are now in 10 years? She immediately responded, nope, I definitely won't be smoking this way in 10 years. You know, implying that there was something about her current use that she could admit was not healthy. So I said to her, okay, well, you don't want to be smoking this way in 10 years. How about five years? She says, no, I don't want to be smoking this way in five years. And I said, okay, how about in a year? And then she stopped and kind of thought about it. And she said, okay, I get where you're going with this stock.
你基本上是在告诉我，如果我不想在10年、5年或1年后这样做，为什么不现在就尝试停止呢？我说，没错。然后她同意了。结果如何？非常有趣。四周后她回来了，她说，伦姆克医生，你不会相信的。这太搞笑了。
You're basically telling me if I don't want to be doing it in 10 years or five years or a year from now, why not try stopping now? And I said, exactly. And then she agreed to do it. And how did it turn out? Really interesting. She came back four weeks later and she said, Dr. Lamkey, you wouldn't believe it. And this is what's so funny.
患者总是会说“你不会相信的”，好像我会感到震惊一样。我说，告诉我。她说，嗯，首先，戒掉大麻让我意识到我一直对大麻上瘾，这是我以前真的没有意识到的。我说，好吧，你是怎么意识到这一点的？她说，嗯，首先，第一周，我剧烈呕吐。
The patients will always say, you wouldn't believe it as if I'm gonna be shocked. I said, tell me. She goes, well, first of all, stopping pot made me realize that I had been addicted to pot, something I really didn't realize before. And I said, well, how did you realize that? And she said, well, first of all, the first week, I was vomiting violently.
所以请记住，戒断反应在心理和生理上都是药物为我们所做的一切的对立面。我们知道大麻可以有止吐或抗恶心的效果。所以当她停止使用它时，她开始呕吐。这对她来说是一个信号，表明她的身体已经被她长期的重度使用所改变。甚至在她的案例中，这比我警告过她的暂时增加的焦虑和失眠更严重。然后她说，而且你不会相信，但在停止四周后，我感觉比很长一段时间以来都要好得多。我感到不那么焦虑了。我感到不那么抑郁了。我更能享受事物了。我呼吸更顺畅了。我身体感觉更好。我睡得更好了。这种情况一次又一次地发生。
So remember that withdrawal is the opposite, both psychologically and physiologically, from whatever the drug was doing for us. And we know that cannabis can be an anti-immatic or, you know, or anti-nazia kind of effect. So when she stopped using it, she started vomiting. And that was the signal to her that her body had been changed by her chronic heavy use. More even in her case than the increased, temporarily increased anxiety and insomnia, which I had warned her about. And then she said, and you wouldn't believe it, but I feel so much better now after four
我们在临床护理中经常看到这种情况，人们感到非常惊讶，因为当我们身处其中时，我们看不到危害。我们所知道的只是，哦，天哪，在漫长而艰难的一天后，抽这根大麻烟让我感觉更好。我们看不到累积效应实际上是如何让我们感觉更糟的。所以，这并不是唯一一个发现她认为自己正在用药物治疗的症状实际上可能是由药物引起的患者。我了解到在这方面已经有了研究，不仅是观察个别患者，还有一个对一组也患有临床抑郁症的酗酒男性进行的经典研究。告诉我关于那个研究以及它发现了什么，安娜。是的，这是布朗和舒克特的一项著名研究，他们选取了一组符合酗酒临床标准，同时也符合重度抑郁发作临床标准的成年男性。
weeks of stopping than I have in a really long time. I feel less anxious. I feel less depressed. I'm more able to enjoy things. I can breathe better. I feel physically better. I'm sleeping better. And this happens again and again and again.
他们把他们送进医院四周，在此期间他们无法接触酒精。你知道，他们确保他们没有生命危险的戒断反应，但在此期间他们也没有给他们任何针对重度抑郁的特定或一般治疗。他们发现，在四周结束时，80%的这些人不再符合重度抑郁发作的标准。换句话说，仅仅停止饮酒就解决了他们的抑郁症。
We see this so often in clinical care and people are so surprised because when we're in it, we don't see the harm. All we know is that, oh, God smoking this joint makes me feel better after a long, hard day. We can't see the ways in which the cumulative effects actually are making us feel worse. So this is not the only client who discovered that the symptoms she thought she was treating with the drug might actually have been caused by the drug. I understand that there has been research on this front not just looking at individual patients, but a classic study conducted with a group of alcoholic men who also had clinical depression. Tell me about that study and what it found on her. clinical depression. Tell me about that study and what it found on it. Yeah, so this is a famous study by Brown and Shucket where they took a group of adult
这与我们在临床上看到的情况非常一致，那些患有焦虑、抑郁、失眠和注意力问题的人，仅仅通过停止他们选择的物质或行为四周，在80%的就诊患者中，大部分症状都得到了解决。我的意思是，这与你更大的假设一致，即这是“富足悖论”在起作用，即我们头脑中触发多巴胺的事物过剩，导致大脑中的那些小妖精在跷跷板的另一侧压得太重，以至于现在，你知道，我们走来走去感到抑郁和焦虑，如果我们试图回到平衡，当我们不再追逐
men who met clinical criteria for alcoholism and also met clinical criteria for major depressive episodes. They put them in the hospital for four weeks during which time they had no access to alcohol. You know, they made sure they didn't have life that threatening withdrawal, but also during which time they gave them no specific or general treatment for major depression. And what they found is at the end of those four weeks, 80% of those individuals no longer met criteria for major depressive episode. In other words, just stopping drinking resolved their depression.
那些快感来摆脱抑郁感时，我们会感觉好得多。是的，完全正确。我们显然正处于一场严重的心理健康危机之中，特别是影响着我们的年轻人，对于为什么会这样有很多猜测。我提出的一个假设是，我们不快乐的根源实际上是我们对快乐的不懈追求。当今世界上许多使之成为可能的“药物化”事物。以及我们的大脑试图通过进入这种多巴胺赤字状态来补偿这一点的方式，
And that is very consistent with what we see clinically, people who have anxiety, depression, insomnia, and attention just by stopping their substance or behavior of choice for four weeks, largely resolves many of those symptoms in about 80% of patients who come in. of those symptoms in about 80% of patients who come in. I mean, this is consistent with your larger hypothesis that this is the plenty paradox at work that the overabundance of things that trigger dopamine in our heads is causing those gremlins in our brain to sort of lean so hard on the other side of the tita totter that now, you know, we are walking around feeling depressed and anxious, and if we try and just get back to equilibrium, we're going to feel much better when we're not chasing
这与临床抑郁症或焦虑、失眠等非常相似。所以你在这里提出的最重要的主张之一是，我们许多人如今所处的富足之海，是导致我们许多人实际上可能比30年前、50年前、100年前更不快乐的根本原因。我们确定这两者之间存在因果联系吗？如果是这样，我们如何确定这一点，安娜？这是一个基于推论的假设，但让我告诉你数据点是什么。首先，当你查看幸福感调查时，大约50年前，你可以追踪到
those highs anymore to get rid of our feelings of depression. Yeah, exactly. We're clearly in the midst of a severe mental health crisis, especially affecting our use, and there's lots of speculation for why that is. And a hypothesis that I would, you know, I've put forward is this idea that the source of our on happiness is in fact our relentless pursuit of pleasure. The many drugified things in our world today that make that possible. And the ways that our brains are trying to compensate for that by actually going into this dopamine deficit state,
生活在更富裕国家的人比生活在贫穷国家的人更快乐，而且随着时间的推移，他们变得越来越快乐。大约20年前开始，世界上最富裕国家的人开始变得越来越不快乐。现在，其原因是什么，我们不确定，但你可以像我一样做出推论，即我们在富足方面达到了某种临界点，在那里，
which is very similar to clinical depression or anxiety and somnia, et cetera. So one of the most important claims that you're making here is that the sea of plenty in which many of us find ourselves in nowadays is Causily responsible for the fact that many of us actually might be more unhappy than we were 30 years ago 50 years ago 100 years ago Are we sure that there is a causal connection between those two things and if so, how are we sure of that Anna? It's a hypothesis based on inference, but let me tell you what the data points are. First of all, when you look at happiness surveys, about 50 years ago, you could track that
最初的好事变成了过剩，现在实际上正在导致我们的痛苦。顺便说一句，这对于全世界范围内不断上升的抑郁、焦虑和自杀率也同样适用，这些比率在全世界都在上升，但在最富裕的国家上升得最快。所以，又是这种“富足悖论”。即使在美国，青少年的焦虑、抑郁和自杀念头也在上升，这与过去20年以及人们花在互联网和消费数字媒体上的时间增加直接相关。然后你有一个小得多的数据点，那就是当我们干预
people who were living in wealthier nations were more happy than people living in poor nations and that they were getting happier over time. Starting about 20 years ago, people in the richest countries in the world started to be less and less happy. Now, what the cause of that is, we don't know for sure, but you could make the inferences as I have done that we reach some kind of tipping point in terms of abundance, where what
并要求人们停止摄入这些高奖励物质和行为时，我们临床上所看到的，那些来寻求焦虑、抑郁和自杀念头帮助的人。我们发现，绝大多数人的焦虑、抑郁和自杀念头在不进行任何其他干预，仅仅是切断一段时间的高多巴胺物质和行为的情况下，都会好转。当我们回来时，将探讨控制成瘾行为的技术，以及关系和社区在帮助我们重置大脑方面可以发挥的关键作用。
started out as a good thing became an overabundance and is actually contributing now to our suffering. And by the way, that holds true also for increasing rates of depression anxiety and suicide all over the world, which are going up all over the world, but which are rising fastest in the wealthiest nations. So again, this kind of plenty paradox. You have even here in the United States rising rates of anxiety depression and suicidal thinking among teenagers, corresponding specifically with the past 20 years, and the increasing amounts of time that people are spending on the internet and consuming digital media. And then you have a much smaller data point, which is what we see clinically when we intervene
你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。精神病学家安娜·伦姆克是《多巴胺国度：在放纵时代寻找平衡》的作者。她认为，当我们不断地寻求快乐时，无论这些快乐是合法的放纵还是非法的物质，我们都会扰乱大脑的神经化学。矛盾的是，我们越追逐快乐，大脑就越试图补偿，
and ask people to stop ingesting these high reward substances and behaviors, people who come in seeking help for anxiety, depression, and suicidal thinking. And what we find is that their anxiety, depression, and suicidal thoughts in the vast majority get better without having to do anything else other than cut out for a period of time their high dopamine substances and behaviors. When we come back techniques to get addictive behaviors on the control and the crucial role that relationships and community can play in helping us to reset our brains.
让我们处于多巴胺耗尽的状态。安娜推荐了多种技术来帮助控制放纵。她称这些为“自我约束技术”。自我约束技术在我们与我们选择的物质或行为之间创造了字面意义上和元认知的障碍，这样我们就可以在欲望和消费之间按下暂停键。有很多不同的方法可以做到这一点。我将其组织为时间、空间和意义，以给我们一个能够戒除的战斗机会。那么这些看起来会是什么样呢？你知道，例如，你谈到的物理或空间自我约束，
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Psychiatrist Anna Lemke is the author of Dopamine Nation, finding balance in the age of indulgence. She argues that when we seek out pleasures on a non-stop basis, whether those pleasures are legal indulgences or illegal substances, we mess with the neurochemistry of the brain. substances, we mess with the neurochemistry of the brain. Paradoxically, the more we chase pleasure, the more the brain tries to compensate,
那看起来是什么样子的？这看起来就像，例如，家里没有那种物质，如果是酒精、薯片、饼干或其他任何东西，家里没有它是一个非常简单的做法。我的患者谈到他们旅行时，提前给酒店打电话，让酒店把房间里的迷你吧移走，在某些情况下，移走迷你吧和电视机。这样人们就不会接触到那些让他们脆弱的有线电视频道。我曾让患者使用像厨房保险箱这样的东西，
leaving us in a dopamine depleted state. Anna recommends multiple techniques to help get indulgences under control. She calls these self-binding techniques. Self-binding techniques create both literal and medicognitive barriers between ourselves and our substance or behavior of choice so that we can press the pause button between desire and consumption. And there are many different ways to do that. I sort of organize it into time space and meaning to give us a fighting chance to be able to abstain. So what would what would some of these look like? You know, for example, the the physical or spatial self-binding that
你知道，这样他们就把设备锁在里面，在一段时间内无法取出。决定你什么时候参与某项活动有时也有帮助。这就是将时间作为自我约束结构的方法。我认为非常有趣的是，我们在现代世界中围绕奖励组织时间的方式，我认为这是前所未有的。你知道，我们期待早上的咖啡，然后我们迫不及待地想晚上回家看我们的节目。所以我要求患者做的是意识到这一点，然后利用时间为自己谋利。
you talk about, what does that look like? That looks like, for example, not having the substance in the house, if it's alcohol or potato chips or cookies or whatever it is not having it in the house is a really simple one. My patients talk about when they travel, calling the hotel in advance and having the hotel remove the mini bar from the room, in some cases remove the mini bar and the television set. So there's not access to the kind of cable channels that make people vulnerable. I've had patients use things like the kitchen
例如，如果他们已经完成了多巴胺禁食，现在他们想回去使用他们的物质或行为，但他们想适度使用，他们可以承诺，例如，每周只玩两天电子游戏，每天两小时，并明确具体时间。或者如果他们想在社交媒体上无意识地刷屏，他们可以说，好吧，我每天要投入半小时，这就是时间，然后我知道我要进行无意识的刷屏或观看YouTube，但除此之外，我不会那样做，或者我会等到我，你知道，完成这次考试或交了论文，得到这次工作晋升，然后
safe, you know, so that they lock their device in there, they can't get it out for a certain period of time. It could also sometimes help to decide when you are going to engage in an activity. So this is the way to use time as a self-winding construct. What I think is really interesting is the way that we essentially organize our time around rewards in the modern world in a way that I think is unprecedented. You know, we sort of look forward to our coffee in the morning and then we can't wait to get home at night and watch our shows. And so what I ask patients to do is to be aware of that and then use time to their advantage.
利用这一点作为约束自己的方式。我了解到你有一位患者米奇，他沉迷于体育博彩，他不得不采取一些相当极端的措施来约束自己，以防止自己使用他选择的药物。是的，所以他不得不做一种叫做“自我禁止”的事情，他基本上去了赌场，把自己列入了一个禁入名单，这在病态赌徒中非常普遍，
For example, if they've done the dopamine fast and now they want to go back to using their substance or behavior, but they want to use in moderation, they could commit to, for example, only playing video games two days a week, two hours a day and specify when that is. Or if they want to have some mindless scrolling on social media they can say okay I'm gonna dedicate a half hour a day and this is when it's gonna be and then I know I'm gonna do mindless scrolling or YouTube watching but outside of that I'm not gonna do that or I'm gonna wait till I you know finish this exam or turn in my paper get this job promotion and
病态体育博彩者。这在新的在线应用程序上确实很难，但你也可以在在线应用程序上禁止自己。他做的另一件事是避免我所说的“垫脚石效应”，即某些行为不一定是我们要选择的物质或行为，但它们是通往该行为的垫脚石。所以他意识到他不能以任何身份观看体育比赛。他不能在报纸上读关于体育的内容。他不能听体育广播。他不能在电视或电脑上观看体育比赛。因为一旦他那样做了，赌博的渴望就会变得势不可挡。
then to use that as a way to bind themselves. I understand you had a patient Mitch, who was addicted to sports gambling, and he had to take some pretty extreme measures to bind himself, to keep himself from using his drug of choice. Yeah, so he had to do something called self-banning, where he basically went to the casinos and put him on a himself on a band list, which is very common among pathological gamblers,
然后以此作为一种约束自己的方式。我了解到你有一位名叫米奇的病人，他沉迷于体育博彩，为了防止自己再次使用这种“毒品”，他不得不采取一些非常极端的手段来约束自己。是的，他不得不进行所谓的“自我禁入”，也就是他亲自去赌场把自己列入禁入名单，这在病态赌徒中非常普遍，
pathological sports betters. It's really hard with the new online apps, but you can also ban yourself on an online app. The other thing that he did was he avoided what I call the stepping stone effect, where certain behaviors are not necessarily our substance or behavior of choice, but they're a stepping stone to it. So he realized that he couldn't really watch sports in any capacity. He couldn't read about sports in the paper. He couldn't listen to sports radio. He couldn't watch sports on television or on the computer. Because as soon as he did that, the end of cravings to bet were just overwhelming.
以及病态体育博彩者中。随着新的在线应用程序的出现，这变得非常困难，但你也可以在在线应用程序上将自己列入禁入名单。他做的另一件事是避免了我所说的“垫脚石效应”，即某些行为虽然不一定是我们选择的物质或行为本身，但却是通往它们的垫脚石。因此他意识到，他实际上根本不能观看任何体育赛事。他不能在报纸上阅读体育新闻，不能收听体育广播，也不能在电视或电脑上观看体育比赛。因为一旦他这样做，那种想要下注的强烈渴望就会让他无法承受。
I mean, this is like people who have let's say an alcohol dependence problem and you know, your taught, you know, don't walk by the bar on your way home from work, you know, take a different route. So in other words, the things that you put in your environment end up shaping the choices that you make. Oh, absolutely. Such a key point. To expect ourselves to be able to change
我的意思是，这就像那些有酒精依赖问题的人，你知道，有人会教你，下班回家路上不要经过酒吧，换条路走。换句话说，你置身于什么样的环境，最终就会塑造你所做出的选择。哦，绝对是这样。这是一个非常关键的观点。如果我们期望自己能够改变
without changing our environment in a dopamine overloaded world is just expecting us to not be human. I deal with a lot of families where the kids are addicted to video games or social media. And the parents are like, I don't know why he just won't stop or she just won't stop. Meanwhile, their house is like fiber optic, high speed internet. They've got a screen in every room in every bedroom. Everybody's got 12 devices. That no, right? No. And also it's school's huge problem. Like, you know, the kids are allowed to have their phone that during class, how can a teacher
而在一个多巴胺过载的世界里却不改变我们的环境，那简直是不切实际的。我接触过很多家庭，他们的孩子沉迷于电子游戏或社交媒体。父母们会说，我不知道他为什么就是停不下来，或者她为什么就是停不下来。与此同时，他们家里用的是光纤高速互联网。每个房间、每间卧室都有屏幕。每个人都有12台设备。这不对，对吧？不对。而且学校也是个大问题。比如，你知道，孩子们在课堂上被允许使用手机，老师怎么可能
possibly compete with YouTube? There's no way. So one of the most radical suggestions that you have and radical in the sense that I think it would appear to many people to be very counterintuitive and how to digest is that one way to deal with compulsive overconsumption is to actively seek out its opposite. You say that we should deliberately seek out experiences of pain and hardship. Now most of us try our best to avoid pain. Why would we choose to deliberately invite pain into our lives? Yeah, I know this sounds really wackadoodle, but there's actually science behind it. It's the science of Hormesis, and Hormesis is Greek for to set in motion.
和YouTube竞争呢？根本不可能。所以你提出的最激进的建议之一——之所以说激进，是因为我认为对许多人来说，这似乎非常违反直觉，难以消化——那就是应对强迫性过度消费的一种方法是主动寻求它的对立面。你说我们应该刻意寻求痛苦和磨难的体验。现在我们大多数人都在尽力避免痛苦。我们为什么要选择刻意把痛苦引入我们的生活呢？是的，我知道这听起来真的很疯狂，但背后其实是有科学依据的。这就是“毒物兴奋效应”（Hormesis）的科学，Hormesis在希腊语中意为“启动”。
And what we're talking about is very mild to moderate doses of adaptive or healthy pain as tolerated. And if you don't like the word pain, maybe use the word discomfort or challenge or something along those lines, although often it does involve some physical duress at the right doses to up-regulate our own healing mechanisms but not so much that it causes irreversible harm. And what the science of Hormesis shows
我们所谈论的是在可承受范围内，适度或温和地摄入适应性或健康的“痛苦”。如果你不喜欢“痛苦”这个词，也许可以用“不适”、“挑战”或类似的词，尽管它通常确实涉及一些身体上的压力，在合适的剂量下可以上调我们自身的修复机制，但又不至于造成不可逆的伤害。而毒物兴奋效应的科学表明
in humans and in animals is that if you expose an organism to mild to moderate doses of painful, toxic, or noxious stimuli, but also some emerging evidence for ice cold water plunges. There's also some evidence showing that prayer and meditation, which are not necessarily painful, but do require effortful engagement and a certain kind of concentration, which is not immediately necessarily pleasurable. That all that those behaviors also really stope me in things like exposure therapy, forcing ourselves to do things that make us psychologically uncomfortable.
在人类和动物身上，如果你让有机体接触适度或温和的痛苦、有毒或有害刺激，但也有一些新兴证据表明冰水浴也有类似效果。还有一些证据表明，祈祷和冥想——虽然不一定痛苦，但确实需要费力的投入和某种程度的专注，这并不一定能立即带来快感——所有这些行为也确实能起到作用，就像暴露疗法一样，强迫自己去做那些让我们心理上感到不舒服的事情。
These are all things that are hard in the initial experience, but essentially trigger our body to sense injury, and in sensing injury injury our bodies start to up-regulate our protective hormones like again our endogenous opioids all ultimately leading to the release of dopamine. So it's a really great way to overall reset our hedonic or joy threshold to the side of pleasure which means that we're more resilient in the face of pain and we're generally happier. Let me summarize what you're saying and make sure I'm understanding this correctly.
这些事情在最初体验时都很困难，但本质上会触发我们的身体感知到损伤，而在感知到损伤时，我们的身体开始上调我们的保护性激素，比如我们的内源性阿片类物质，最终都会导致多巴胺的释放。所以，这是一个重置我们享乐或快乐阈值，使其回归平衡的绝佳方法，这意味着我们在面对痛苦时更有韧性，而且总体上会更快乐。让我总结一下你所说的，确保我理解得正确。
Your central argument here is that there is a system in the brain that tries to maintain homeostasis. When we press down on the pleasure side of the balance, the brain gremlins get on the pain side of the balance or try and compensate it in recover equilibrium. But if we were to press down on the pain side of the balance, now homeostasis starts to work in some ways in our favor because the gremlins hop onto the pleasure side of the balance and they basically get us to a state where we're feeling better on average than we were doing before. That's exactly right. And there is overwhelming evidence to support this. So for example, we know that if you track dopamine levels as well as other feel good neurotransmitters like endogenous serotonin, or epnafran endogenous opioids, endogenous cannabinoids,
你的核心论点是，大脑中有一个试图维持稳态的系统。当我们按下平衡的快乐一侧时，大脑中的“小精灵”就会跳到平衡的痛苦一侧，试图补偿并恢复平衡。但如果我们按下平衡的痛苦一侧，现在稳态在某种程度上开始对我们有利，因为小精灵会跳到平衡的快乐一侧，它们基本上会让我们达到一种平均感觉比以前更好的状态。完全正确。而且有压倒性的证据支持这一点。例如，我们知道，如果你追踪多巴胺水平以及其他感觉良好的神经递质，如内源性血清素、去甲肾上腺素、内源性阿片类物质、内源性大麻素，
what you find is that initially when people engage in exercise, those neurotransmitters are low, but over the latter half of exercise, they slowly start to rise. And then when the exercise is stopped, those neurotransmitter levels remain elevated for hours afterwards. And of course, this is our runner's high. And then eventually, those elevated levels of dopamine will go back down to baseline levels, homeostasis, but without ever going into that dopamine deficit state.
你会发现，人们在运动初期，这些神经递质水平很低，但在运动的后半段，它们开始缓慢上升。然后当运动停止时，这些神经递质水平会在之后持续升高数小时。当然，这就是我们的“跑步者高潮”。最终，这些升高的多巴胺水平会回到基线水平，即稳态，但永远不会进入那种多巴胺匮乏的状态。
In other words, by paying for our dopamine up front, we get those feel good experiences, which we need, right? We're humans. We can't just like hang out in homeostasis, but we can get those good feelings without ever having to go into our cash dopamine reserves, so to speak. You made an interesting analogy a second ago, and I want to just draw attention to it, which is that there is an analogy here between the way we engage with our brains and the way
换句话说，通过预先支付我们的多巴胺，我们获得了那些感觉良好的体验，这是我们所需要的，对吧？我们是人类。我们不能只是待在稳态里，但我们可以在不必动用我们的“多巴胺现金储备”的情况下获得那些良好的感觉。你刚才做了一个有趣的类比，我想提请注意，那就是我们与大脑的互动方式与我们
we engage with money. You can buy things on credit, and that is sometimes valuable and smart to do. But it does mean that you're getting the good stuff first and then paying for it later. So that's what we do when we intentionally trigger dopamine in our heads. We're getting the good feelings now, but have to deal with it later. You're arguing that focusing on the pain side of the equation in some ways is, as you say, paying for the dopamine up front, you're doing the difficult thing now in exchange for the reward down the road. Exactly. And you can see the ways in which actually the way we pay for things makes us all more vulnerable to addiction because now they have these credit cards where you don't even
与金钱的互动方式之间存在类比。你可以通过信贷购买东西，这有时是有价值且明智的。但这确实意味着你先得到了好东西，然后再付钱。这就是我们刻意触发大脑多巴胺时所做的事情。我们现在得到了良好的感觉，但以后必须为此付出代价。你认为关注等式的痛苦一侧在某种程度上就是你所说的“预先支付多巴胺”，你现在做困难的事情，以换取未来的奖励。完全正确。你可以看到，我们支付东西的方式实际上使我们更容易上瘾，因为现在他们有了信用卡，你甚至不需要
have to pay for them in real time, you can pay for them later, which is just terrible. I'm wondering if it will sound to many people that you're almost recommending a life of, you know, a setisism here. Are you recommending that people become ascetic, Santa? I'm recommending a new form of asceticism for the modern age. And what I mean by that is we are living in an unprecedented time of overwhelming access to highly reinforcing drugs and behaviors such that I think that our existence is going to be reliant upon figuring out how to navigate
实时支付，你可以以后再付，这简直太糟糕了。我想知道，对许多人来说，这听起来是否几乎是在建议一种“禁欲主义”的生活。你是在建议人们成为苦行僧吗，安娜？我是在为现代社会建议一种新的禁欲主义。我的意思是，我们正生活在一个前所未有的时代，人们可以过度获取高度强化的药物和行为，以至于我认为我们的生存将依赖于弄清楚如何驾驭
this world of overabundance. And so in fact, in order to be healthy, we actually have to intentionally veer slightly to the side of pain and insulate ourselves from pleasure in order to preserve balance. Have you done this yourself? Oh yeah, I do this on a regular basis. What do you do? What do you do? Well, I like to start my day with pain, namely doing some kind of exercise, mainly walking or swimming because I'm in my 50s now. But every morning, when I wake up, trust me, I do not want to get out of bed, but I absolutely force myself to do it most of the time because I know I'll feel so much better afterwards. And it's just a great, angiallytic and mood stabilizer for me. And then we've raised our family with a lot of, you know, forced marches
这个过度丰饶的世界。因此，事实上，为了健康，我们实际上必须刻意稍微偏向痛苦的一侧，并让自己与快乐隔绝，以保持平衡。你自己这样做过吗？哦，是的，我经常这样做。你做什么？你做什么？嗯，我喜欢以痛苦开始我的一天，也就是做某种运动，主要是走路或游泳，因为我已经50多岁了。但每天早上，当我醒来时，相信我，我一点也不想起床，但我绝大多数时候都强迫自己去做，因为我知道之后我会感觉好得多。这对我来说是一个很好的抗焦虑和情绪稳定剂。然后我们抚养孩子时也用了大量的，你知道，强制行军
and outdoor wilderness experiences which were challenging and difficult. We've insulated ourselves from digital media in the sense that we didn't have any devices or Wi-Fi, even Wi-Fi to the home until our eldest went to high school. And then she came back and said that she essentially couldn't function as a high school student without Wi-Fi in the home. They change the schedule every day. You have to log on everything just to know what class you're supposed to go to. It's crazy.
和户外荒野体验，这些都是充满挑战和困难的。我们在数字媒体方面让自己与世隔绝，因为在我们的长女上高中之前，我们没有任何设备，甚至家里连Wi-Fi都没有。后来她回来后说，没有家里的Wi-Fi，她基本上无法作为一名高中生正常学习。他们每天都在改变时间表。你必须登录所有东西才能知道你应该去上什么课。这太疯狂了。
So, I'm really sad because now we have Wi-Fi and fiber optic and it makes it a lot harder for me personally to manage my consumption because like I'll get into these bad YouTube watching habits in the evenings, you know, you can just imagine. But anyway, that's something that we did. We bike a lot of places instead of driving. In fact, we have one 25 year old minivan, which has 75,000 miles on it. And one of my husband tried to re register for the insurance. They didn't believe us that it only had 75,000 miles.
所以，我真的很伤心，因为现在我们有了Wi-Fi和光纤，这让我个人更难管理我的消费，因为比如我会在晚上养成看YouTube的坏习惯，你知道，你可以想象一下。但无论如何，这是我们做过的事情。我们很多地方都骑自行车而不是开车。事实上，我们有一辆25年的小型货车，里程只有75,000英里。我丈夫试图重新注册保险时，他们不相信我们只有75,000英里。
And they made us like get an affidavit. Yeah. So what is the reward for living this way, Ana? What do you see in your life? Do you think you're seeing effects in your mind on your brain? Oh, yeah. I used to think that my life was really hard and that that was the source of my unhappiness,
他们让我们去弄一份宣誓书。是的。那么，这样生活的回报是什么，安娜？你在生活中看到了什么？你认为你在你的思想和大脑上看到了效果吗？哦，是的。我过去认为我的生活真的很艰难，那是我不快乐的根源，
but now I actually think that all along my life was actually too easy, and that's why I was unhappy. One of the most striking things about stories of addiction is that they often involve increasing levels of social isolation. Think of the person who is up playing endless first person shoot-of-video games in an apartment by himself at 4 o'clock in the morning, or the furtive, heavy consumer of pornography. The young woman addicted to pot.
但现在我实际上认为，一直以来我的生活其实太容易了，这就是我不快乐的原因。关于成瘾故事最引人注目的事情之一是，它们通常涉及社会孤立程度的加深。想想那个凌晨4点独自在公寓里玩无尽第一人称射击游戏的人，或者偷偷摸摸、大量消费色情制品的人。那个对大麻上瘾的年轻女性。
And I feel like we may have painted an overly negative picture of dopamine in this conversation. Yes, you can have an unhealthy relationship with dopamine, but the problem is not with dopamine per se, but the ways we go about triggering it. You say that relationships are a powerful way to trigger dopamine in a healthy fashion. Can you talk about that idea? Yeah, so my colleague, Rob Malenka here at Stanford is neuroscientist. He and his colleagues have shown that oxytocin, which is our love hormone, binds to dopamine-releasing neurons in the reward pathway.
我觉得我们在这次谈话中可能把多巴胺描绘得过于负面了。是的，你可能与多巴胺有不健康的关系，但问题不在于多巴胺本身，而在于我们触发它的方式。你说人际关系是一种以健康方式触发多巴胺的强大途径。你能谈谈那个想法吗？是的，我的同事，斯坦福大学的神经科学家罗伯·马伦卡（Rob Malenka），他和他的同事们已经证明，催产素，也就是我们的“爱情荷尔蒙”，会与奖励通路中的多巴胺释放神经元结合。
So that makes a lot of sense because we know when we fall in love, we feel high, right? That's a great feeling. And from a survival point of view, or an evolutionary point of view, our brains want us to make connections to other people because we're more likely to find mates, more likely to be able to protect ourselves from predators, more likely to be able to steward scarce resources. So our brains get us to make those connections by releasing dopamine and making sure that it feels good. The problem with addiction is that essentially our substance or behavior of choice comes
这很有道理，因为我们知道当我们坠入爱河时，我们会感到兴奋，对吧？那是一种很棒的感觉。从生存的角度或进化的角度来看，我们的大脑希望我们与他人建立联系，因为我们更有可能找到伴侣，更有可能保护自己免受捕食者的伤害，更有可能管理稀缺资源。所以我们的大脑通过释放多巴胺并确保这种感觉良好来促使我们建立这些联系。成瘾的问题在于，本质上我们的物质或行为选择
to replace those human connections. And so we move further and further into isolation. And we meet those basic needs through our drug rather than through making deep human connections. And so part of getting into recovery from addiction means moving out of isolation and trying to make deep and rewarding intimate connections with other people because essentially that's what we're really looking for, but we get fooled by these kinds of false stand-ins for human connection. I'm wondering if you can tell me a little bit about the role of community here.
取代了那些人际联系。于是我们越来越深地陷入孤立。我们通过药物而不是通过建立深厚的人际联系来满足那些基本需求。因此，从成瘾中恢复的一部分意味着走出孤立，尝试与他人建立深厚且有益的亲密关系，因为本质上这才是我们真正想要的，但我们被这些虚假的人际联系替代品所欺骗了。我想知道你能不能告诉我一点关于社区在这里的作用。
There are many groups that have sprung up to try and fight addictions, groups like AA or NA or gamblers anonymous, for example. Tell me about the role that they play, and in some ways is it part of the same equation that we're looking at here, the role of human relationships in battling addiction? Yeah, so AA, I'll call it synonymous and narcotics anonymous, in my opinion, are among the most remarkable social movements
已经涌现出许多试图对抗成瘾的团体，例如匿名戒酒互助会（AA）或匿名戒毒互助会（NA）或匿名赌徒互助会。告诉我它们所扮演的角色，在某种程度上，这是否与我们在这里讨论的等式相同，即人际关系在对抗成瘾中的作用？是的，所以AA，我会称之为匿名戒酒互助会和匿名戒毒互助会，在我看来，是过去100年来最了不起的社会运动之一。
of the last 100 years. These are amazing grassroots organizations, composed of people with addiction, trying to help other people with addiction. And it's remarkably successful for those who actively participate. So you'll read a lot in the media now about how AA and other 12 sub organizations don't work. But that's not really a faithful representation of the evidence. There are many people who will not participate or get anything out of it, but for those who actively participate, engagement in AA and other 12-step groups,
这些是令人惊叹的草根组织，由成瘾者组成，试图帮助其他成瘾者。对于那些积极参与的人来说，它是非常成功的。所以你现在会在媒体上读到很多关于AA和其他12步组织不起作用的文章。但这并不是对证据的忠实陈述。有许多人不会参与或从中得到任何东西，但对于那些积极参与的人来说，参与AA和其他12步团体，
is as effective and possibly even more effective than professional treatment. So what is the secret of these 12-step groups? Well, first of all, they provide a sober social network. They provide a specific path for recovery, but importantly, they're also really deshaming because you realize, oh, wow, I'm not the only one. And like, I have this thing that happened to my brain because I'm human. And I have this particular vulnerability and other people have experienced and done similar things that I have done
其效果与专业治疗一样有效，甚至可能更有效。那么这些12步团体的秘诀是什么呢？嗯，首先，它们提供了一个清醒的社交网络。它们提供了一条具体的康复路径，但重要的是，它们也非常有助于消除羞耻感，因为你意识到，哦，哇，我不是唯一一个。而且，因为我是人类，我的大脑发生了这种事情。我有这种特殊的脆弱性，其他人也经历过并做过和我做过类似的事情，
in pursuit of their drug. And that is an incredible burst of intimacy and yes dopamine, right, that we get then from being taken into the fold of like-minded individuals who understand us and accept us in all our brokenness. One important idea that Anna has adopted in her own life powerfully resonates with a message of groups such as AA and NA. Change begins with telling the truth. Yeah, so this was really something that I learned from my patients.
在追求他们的药物的过程中。这是一种令人难以置信的亲密感爆发，是的，还有多巴胺，对吧？我们从被志同道合的人接纳中获得这些，他们理解我们，并接受我们所有的破碎。安娜在自己生活中采用的一个重要理念与AA和NA等团体的核心信息产生了强烈的共鸣。改变始于说真话。是的，这确实是我从我的病人那里学到的东西。
Over many years of seeing patients get into recovery from severe addictions, what I noticed was that those who seemed to get into the best recovery and be able to maintain recovery the longest were those who were committed to telling the truth. That was a central value for them, which they saw as just pivotal for maintaining sobriety or recovery. And I thought that was really interesting. Like, what is it about truth telling
在多年观察病人从严重成瘾中恢复的过程中，我注意到那些似乎恢复得最好并且能够维持最长康复时间的人，是那些致力于说真话的人。这是一个核心价值观，他们认为这对维持清醒或康复至关重要。我觉得这非常有趣。关于说真话，到底有什么
that enables recovery and enables people to stay in recovery? Because it just was such a consistent theme, whether they got into recovery through 12 steps, AA or NA or just through their own journey, it was inevitable that they would be like, oh yeah, no, I can't lie. And when they said that they weren't just talking about, I can't lie about my addictive behaviors, they meant they couldn't lie about anything. That the lying itself was sort of the first breach in the dam for them, and that they had to be truthful in all things in order to maintain recovery. So that was really interesting to me, and I began to explore that, both from a scientific
能够促进康复并使人们保持康复？因为它是一个如此一致的主题，无论他们是通过12步、AA或NA，还是仅仅通过他们自己的旅程获得康复，他们不可避免地会说，哦，是的，不，我不能撒谎。当他们这样说时，他们指的不仅仅是“我不能在我的成瘾行为上撒谎”，他们指的是他们不能在任何事情上撒谎。撒谎本身对他们来说就像是堤坝上的第一个缺口，为了维持康复，他们必须在所有事情上都诚实。这对我来说非常有趣，我开始探索这一点，无论是从科学
perspective, as well as try to employ it in my own life. One of the things I find so striking about this conversation is that you're someone who spends her day helping patients, but I'm not getting the sense that you see yourself as better or even different from the people you're trying to help. I understand that you're a fan of the philosopher Martin Boober, who has talked about what it's like to truly engage with another person. He talks about this eye and down moment, for Martin Boober, who has talked about what it's like to truly engage with another person. He talks about this eye and down moment, which he believed can occur between any two individuals
的角度，还是尝试在自己的生活中运用它。关于这次谈话，我发现最引人注目的一点是，你是一个每天花时间帮助病人的人，但我并没有感觉到你认为自己比你试图帮助的人更好，甚至不同。我知道你是哲学家马丁·布伯（Martin Buber）的粉丝，他谈论过真正与另一个人接触是什么感觉。他谈论这种“我与你”（I and Thou）的时刻，他认为这可以发生在任何两个人之间
who just make the effort to be fully present with each other. And it's a divine moment, right, where everything else falls away. It's not sexualized love. It's something sexualized love. It's something akin to love, but what's so interesting about this eye-and-dow concept is that it can be achieved in a nanosecond with anybody. You could achieve it with a stranger, this idea, being that when we kind of come to the encounter fully open and vulnerable in our shared humanity and we see each other. That's a really special and remarkable experience and I try to create that in
只要他们努力完全向对方敞开。这是一个神圣的时刻，对吧？其他一切都消失了。这不是性化的爱。这是一种类似于爱的东西，但这个“我与你”概念最有趣的地方在于，它可以与任何人瞬间实现。你可以和一个陌生人实现它，这个想法是，当我们以完全开放和脆弱的姿态进入这种共享的人性中，并且我们真正看见彼此的时候。那是一种非常特别和了不起的体验，我尝试在
my work with patients because that alone is healing. I've probably learned more from my patients than I think I've given them in return. I really given them in return. I really see people in recovery from severe addictions as modern-day profits, because these are folks who have had to figure out pleasure and pain and consumption in a dopamine overloaded world, and they've had to do it as a matter of life and death, and they've been able to do it. And so they really provide this road map of deep wisdom for the rest of us.
我的工作中与病人创造这种体验，因为仅此一点就是治愈。我从病人身上学到的东西可能比我给予他们的还要多。我真的把那些从严重成瘾中恢复过来的人视为现代的先知，因为这些人不得不在一个多巴胺过载的世界里弄清楚快乐、痛苦和消费，他们必须把这当作生死攸关的事情来处理，而且他们做到了。所以他们确实为我们其他人提供了深刻智慧的路线图。
Anna Lemke is a psychiatrist and a researcher in the behavioral sciences at Stanford University. She's the author of Dopamine Nation, finding balance in the age of indulgence. Anna, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Oh, you're welcome. It was a real pleasure. If you have follow-up questions for Ana Lemki about the science of addiction and are willing to have those questions shared with a larger hidden brain audience. Please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideasathydenbrain.org. 60 seconds is plenty.
安娜·伦姆克（Anna Lembke）是斯坦福大学的精神病学家和行为科学研究员。她是《多巴胺国度：在放纵时代寻找平衡》（Dopamine Nation）的作者。安娜，非常感谢你今天参加我们的《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）节目。哦，不客气。这真是我的荣幸。如果你有关于成瘾科学的后续问题想问安娜·伦姆克，并且愿意让这些问题与更广泛的《隐藏的大脑》听众分享，请在手机上录制一段语音备忘录，并通过电子邮件发送给我们：ideas@hiddenbrain.org。60秒就足够了。
Please remember to include your name and a phone number where we can reach you. Again email the question to us at ideasathydenbrain.org and use the subject line, Addiction. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Ani Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. A Ran Sankiro this week is Howard Wolfe. Howard is president of the Stanford Alumni Association, and he invited me some time ago to attend a symposium
请记得包括你的名字和一个我们可以联系到你的电话号码。再次强调，请将问题通过电子邮件发送给我们：ideas@hiddenbrain.org，并使用主题行“Addiction”。《隐藏的大脑》由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括Bridget McCarthy、Ani Murphy-Paul、Kristen Wong、Laura Quarell、Ryan Katz、Autumn Barnes和Andrew Chadwick。Tara Boyle是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。本周的Ran Sankiro是Howard Wolfe。Howard是斯坦福大学校友会的会长，他很久以前邀请我参加一个研讨会，
featuring interesting research at the university. Anna Lemke was one of the speakers, and within minutes of listening to her, I knew we needed to have her on Hidden Brain. Howard is one of the most wise and generous people I know and a gifted communicator in his own right. Thanks for putting these great ideas on our radar Howard. If you would like to help us build more stories like this, please act now. Visit support.hiddenbrain.org and join the hundreds of other hidden brain listeners who have agreed to help.
展示大学里有趣的研究。安娜·伦姆克是演讲者之一，听她讲了几分钟后，我就知道我们需要请她来《隐藏的大脑》。Howard是我认识的最睿智、最慷慨的人之一，他本身也是一位天才的沟通者。感谢你让我们关注到这些伟大的想法，Howard。如果你想帮助我们制作更多这样的故事，请现在行动。访问support.hiddenbrain.org，加入其他数百位同意提供帮助的《隐藏的大脑》听众行列。
Again, that support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再次强调，网址是support.hiddenbrain.org。我是Shankar Vedantam。很快再见。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。